we're asked to determine the solution
set of this system and we actually have
three inequalities right here and a good
place to start is just to graph the sets
the solution sets for each of these
inequalities and then see where they
overlap and that's the region of the x y
coordinate plane that will satisfy all
of them so let's first graph well let's
just graph y is equal to 2x plus 1 and
that that includes this line and then
it's all the points greater than that as
well so the y-intercept right here is 1.
if x is zero y is one and the slope is
two if we move forward in the x
direction one we move up two if we move
forward two we'll move up
four
just like that so this graph is going to
look something like this let me graph a
couple of more points here just so that
i
make sure that i'm drawing it reasonably
accurately so it would look something
like this
it looks
something
something like that that's the graph of
y is equal to 2x plus 1. now for y is
greater than or equal or if it's equal
or greater than so we have to put all
the region above this for any x 2x plus
1 will be right on that line but all the
y's greater than that are also valid so
the solution set of that first equation
is all of this area up here
all of the area above
above the line
including the line because it's greater
than or equal to so that's this first
inequality right there now let's do the
second inequality the second inequality
is y is less than 2x minus 5. so if we
were to graph 2x minus 5 and something
already might jump out at you that these
two are parallel to each other they have
the same slope so 2x minus 5 y-intercept
is negative 5. x is 0 y is negative 1
negative 2 negative 3 negative 4
negative 5.
slope is 2 again and this is only less
than strictly less than so we're not
going to actually include the line the
slope is 2
the slope is 2 so to look something like
that has the exact same slope as this
other line
slope is 2 so i could draw a bit of a
dotted line here if you like
and we're not going to include the
dotted line because we're strictly less
than so the solution set for this second
inequality is going to be all of the
area below the line right for any x this
is 2x minus 5 and we care about the y's
that are less than that so let me shade
that in
so before we even get
before we even get to this last
inequality in order for there to be
something that satisfies both of these
inequalities it has to be in both of
their solution sets because you can see
their solution sets are completely
non-overlapping there's no point on the
xy plane that is in both of these
solution sets they're separated by this
kind of no-man's land between these two
parallel lines so there is actually no
solution set it's actually the null set
there's the empty set maybe we could put
an empty set like that you know two
brackets with nothing in it there's no
solution center the solution set of the
system is empty i mean we could do the x
is greater than one this is x is equal
to one so we put a dotted line there for
x's because we don't want to include
that so it would be all of this stuff
but once again there's nothing that
satisfies all three of these this area
right here satisfies the bottom two this
area up here satisfies the last one in
the first one but nothing there's
nothing that satisfies both these top
two empty set